[Music]
was that number two frozen
we want number two
that wasn't a tomato give me a number
can you please give me number two can i
please swap out please okay i'll take
number two whatever it is yeah i used to
know this guy and it made like the
forgiato blow thing bugs me the most
because
oh no
all right
i did a maternity shoot with my brother
okay go back go back and go back just
kind of a [ __ ] she's gonna be born with
a whole bunch of tattoos i was laughing
but i said i'm gonna get back at him
training first tattoo photo shoot no oh
no
why
why is this
why are you doing this
yeah i can't look at this without
laughing he looks like he's getting
booked into baby prison
dude this looks like it could have been
like a 50 cent album cover back in the
day
get nippled or die trying
come on man what is this awesome is what
it is it's awesome
my family was very upset i get a lot of
backlash
nice back tat bro randy orton over here
look at randy orton
they keep saying
that putin is gonna nuke us
and he never does by the way if you want
to check it out it's uh the instagram is
nuggetworld561
people say i'm raising him as a gangster
well no that's just a picture of lil
wayne
yeah lil wayne now yeah
they not
i can't i can't have the pause
i have to pause it all the
pictures remember the sky's the limit
video with biggie and the kids played
them
yes
yes that's what it is
guys the limit video
not used to seeing a baby with tattoos
and for the people that judge me i don't
care because she doesn't care
she's a cure at all okay but uh there
seems to be a that's the problem you see
there's a common thread with people like
you is that you don't care
and i'm tired of
i'm i'm tired of people saying i don't
occur
as a [ __ ] as this as if that like
morally justifies their actions like you
notice that it doesn't matter if it's
this or one of these polyamory videos or
one of these like i'm gonna destroy my
body with modification videos right it's
always well people tell me it's not
healthy and i'm you know killing myself
but i don't care and it's like they say
it like
in that saying that it's like oh what
i'm doing is actually pretty great like
i don't care shouldn't be your battle
cry
i know people say i shouldn't be putting
tattoos on my baby but it's like yolo
[Laughter]
that we enjoy
dance machine oh
of course
florida
what you want to wear i should have
known by the five six one that's the
palm beach area code
the nice part of pumpkin trailing where
most people know him as nugget world as
what
nugget oh
okay that's not what i heard class is
one
he's a celebrity on tick tock he made it
to 1.5 million followers and so we
appreciate that hey my name's shamika
her name's shamika and my son traylin
she's trailing my mom
and i enjoy putting them on them
oh pessy that's mean what did
all right
that's not come on man
i see
you can't you can't i don't think you're
allowed to do that
i
broke mate
i was just putting him in a gta stash
house
oh [ __ ] this is [ __ ] hood [ __ ] dude
um
only mom can judge me judge me
yeah
trailer is one years old
one years old
trying to have tons of clothes
and shoes
what a waste of money on designer
toddler shoes right
it is it is kind of silly
over
oh probably like 150. 150 children's
shoes for a baby to turn go out of him
in three months
sneakers he's a sneaker head no no no no
no he's not he's a baby you're he's
yours you're a sneaker head not him he's
a baby
you know what he looks like
he looks like one of those uh
one of those uh european soccer players
standing in front of all his kicks
[Laughter]
check out my kicks brav
it looks like wiz khalifa got shot with
that honey i shrunk the kid
or [ __ ] some laser science thing that
like turns you into a baby
you don't like mini r truth it's no it's
not
too light-skinned yeah
oh you're fresh
you look good man fresh to death bro
some chains
you're just gonna spill juice from a
sippy cup all of that
uh you mean hennessy from mississippi
cup we gotta keep it real here
that's fly that's pretty fly accessorize
the outfit
i think
that's perfect for today's outfit
i think trailing love dressing up
because
when he sees himself dressed he get in
the mirror he'll be feeding himself hold
on hold on
that's my favorite one
out of all of them i gotta admit
that's my favorite one
that's that miami yeah yeah look at that
look at that vibe dude
violent boy denied boy yes he's an
island boy here look at that
hold on let's go through some of these
come on pessy
let's go to pencey do i look now this
looks like he's one of those like
backpack rappers in this one you know
what i mean yes
oh let's see what did bessie do come on
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i love that he picked the shittiest
house you could find
he's out on the stoop can we get a
picture of him in south beach on spring
break yeah yeah from from the uh from
the like when there was some
unpleasantness going on
yes please thank you from
the uh
any one of these actually
dancing so i really think he enjoys it
yeah again
he's a baby
he enjoys getting attention i i feel
like i need to keep really really like
underscoring that
he's a baby it was eight months i did a
maternity shoot with my brothers at a
tattoo shop
and i
huh
by the way
it's really a woman for everybody that's
been wondering if it's a dude that's a
woman obviously just a very ugly black
woman got bullied on social media i'll
come why would they bully you on social
media everything you're doing looks
completely normal
it was negative people were saying
oh my baby is going to be born with a
whole bunch of tattoos he's going to
have skin poison
[Music]
your baby's going to be born with a
bunch of tattoos do they not know how
tattoos were people were joking were
making jokes
in her photo shoot pictures i was like
and you thought it was serious
i was laughing trailing first tattoo was
when he was
six months and just the detail of it it
was just so amazing hey hey y'all
come on look at it
[Music]
my celebrity enough room
that's right i'm going to give you guys
a few
celebrity nerf years were
there he is
nugget all up in this [ __ ] look at that
nuggets out there oh yeah hell yeah it's
your turn to see it
check it out there he is
living the good life it's like a worse
waldow
there he is
nobody step on that baby
dancing
so i want to do a photo shoot after
you know the negative comments that are
going to come behind this right
when i first started tattooing trailing
my family hate it wait so does this baby
really have real tattoos i think they're
probably fake i think that's right i
think they're front loading this to make
people shock but i'm pretty sure they're
just like this hannah painted on onesie
okay because i'm pretty sure that would
be child yeah that's from i mean i doubt
it because they don't like that i have
tattoos but now that they seem it could
be something positive they love it
because when we out we get a lot of
attention and kids really love the
tattoos
no he doesn't really cause there he
doesn't have them i think they're like
those peanut you know what i mean you
paint them on the henna ones yeah yeah
when shamika came up with the idea i
wasn't down with it i was totally
against it i did not want her but then
we started making money on tick tock and
i was like damn how do i get me some of
that
do that with him
but since i seen where it could take her
in
trailing
i didn't have no all right now i would
not can you go back yeah
can you freeze frame when they close up
with the kid play with the toy do that
with him
now i don't want anyone photoshopping a
gun in this kid's hands come on don't do
that
i don't want
is any one of you [ __ ]
to go to this video and find a good
frame
and photoshop a gun in his hand okay i
don't want that he brings his arm up a
little bit more when he's playing you
just just let it play a little bit
jesus christ
i don't want it
i do not want a gun in one of these
frames there you go that's probably the
best one i think
don't do that
great now i'm going to get an i'm going
to get a text uh a dm from uh leading me
later and yeah yeah leading me just
going to make his feet big though
with it because it turned out to be a
positive
thing
ready to go
you ready to go
this just makes me feel bad for these
kids
when they get when i'm at work
and she can't like this kid's going to
grow up to be a [ __ ] and it's not his
fault
you know you hear my family oh so nugget
likes nuggets so it's not just a clever
name that's pretty cool
it hurt my feelings because i know i'm
not a bad mom
and i gotta do a call back to frozen
stroke yo [ __ ] i want the ones that
look like dinosaurs
knocks the tray over yeah
[ __ ] i said i wanted the dinosaur ones
all type of names
can't be a gangster gangster he gonna
get um shot down in the screams
in the screen she said screech did you
know you're saying
considering
your lifestyle the fact that you live in
west palm the fact that you're turning
your young black baby into a celebrity
before he's even a kid
and the fact that you use words like
screets yeah i'm saying that the
likelihood is very high that little
nugget is not gonna make it too [ __ ]
jv little nugget
um shot down and screaming
we're raising him up for prison
well
it was just bad i'm just noticing maybe
they were just commenting on the lack of
men in this kid's life
i'm proud of shamika of the life that
she's making for training because she's
trying to pass on a legacy
she don't want her a legacy of what hang
on let her catch her breath she's trying
to explain okay
she's out of breath talking sitting down
she wants better for her son
so yes i'm very proud of her go to the
tattoo shop
what's up bro
her stomach big cover up and i've also
done her legs
she came up with it like about a year
ago
and just felt like it would be a good
idea for a promo and yeah it's just like
so it'll be a way for him to look like
he's headed
[Music]
yeah it's exactly what it is
basically just
place this rag against it right now and
it's so it why
because
what is wrong with you frozen why do you
do this so there's certain associates
oh no
negatives old book
okay you know hold on let me pull it up
you
[Laughter]
there he is
who made that
messy
there's a little nugget
wear be nugget
you people need to grow up